what a l what a l what a l what an
[Music]
absolute ah what a lad well I try and
start every season with a bang by
getting the biggest lad there is he's
literally one of the all-time greats
having played a 100 times for both the
Chiefs and the All Blacks he's won
almost everything there is to win with
Super Rugby titles a Rugby World Cup
plenty of TR naations and blers loads
cups as well and he's even won the World
Player of the Year for being the best
player in the game and who knows at the
end of this Japan season he might have
just have a top League to his collection
as well but on top of all the trophies
and the awards he is one of the true
lads who all the boys love he's an
absolute Champion man it is of course
the great Brody retalic welcome mate
what an intro what an intro it's great
to be on good to get involved mate how
do you feel it when I uh sort of read
all that out cuz you've had some career
especially when you think about where
where it all sort of started for you um
I know you missed out on sort of the
canbury academy and to to sort of get to
where you've got to in your career today
how do you sort of reflect on all of
that yeah it's you know when you when
you you hear someone kind of read it out
like that you think you know it's you've
achieved a lot I guess why you're still
playing and um especially the last kind
of year and a half two years it's it's
always kind of like what's next you know
like with the World Cup just been and
the Super Rugby season just been and and
now you I came home to New Zealand for
about 3 weeks before coming back to
Japan and
four or five games in straight away but
um yeah it's been it's been a hell of a
ride from coming from uh Christ Church
and like I say not really knowing what
was going to happen in terms of even
playing rugby as a career to to what
I've done um I definitely can't complain
that's for sure mate you've had some
career and you mentioned Japan there
like how you finding it over there how
how you and the family enjoying Japan
life yeah we settled them pretty well
like we come back to the cabalo Steelers
where I came um after the 219 World Cup
so just just having that familiarity and
knowing where everything is and kids
have gone back to the same school has
helped um I think the noticeable kind of
Step Up or growth of the game there's
like last time I was here there's
probably four four or five teams that
were really competitive but like you
look at the competition now and there's
probably like nine eight nine teams that
are seriously seriously good and you
know we we've found out pretty sharply
um over these first four games we won
our first two in the first one quite
quite convincingly but lost um a couple
of close ones the last two weeks so uh
go straight into semi-finals and finals
is the way the competition is formatted
so you can't afford to drop too many
that's for sure it hasn't been much in
those games that you've lost though like
um you have got a stacked team on paper
yeah you've been in those games and you
know arguably should have won them as
well yeah um it's been a hard one to
comprehend a couple of losses obviously
we played TOA and we're playing Richie
moang shanon forel I think Shannon end
up scoring four tries against us you on
paper that probably you looks like we
worked to good but yeah we had some um
some tries that were kind of hard to
comprehend or just silly mistakes and um
but like I say you know tough
competitions you got to be B than that
so we're playing Caboda this weekend
which um they won last year and uh have
dropped a couple of games as well and
some familiar faces in there too so
it'll be another tough one yeah a
matchup of the two niggest players in
New Zealand you and Dane Cole's going at
it I can't wait to see Dane out there
again he's um I know they didn't him and
Liam Williams the oh and Bernard foler
the three kind of international caps and
Dan and Liam didn't play the first two
but he's been playing well um the last
two I saw he scored a try last week too
so he'll be right in the thick of it no
doubt will you get stack into him will
you give him some there go I thought
last time we played each other was Chief
V hurricane I thought we're too old for
this now you know like we just leave
each other alone and then he comes on
the field and I'm running back from a
line and I think they kicked it he just
pushes me in the
back oh yeah next next Grandma went
stood on his toes while the referee was
talking to us my
sprs I like to say leave other alone but
I can't see it
happen yeah you two together oh absolute
Shockers yeah I do look forward to it
yeah mate you love it but we will get to
your journey you mentioned growing up in
Christ Church
um what else can you tell us about your
your childhood growing up yeah I think
um you like anyone that kind of comes
from a small town and um I'm a middle of
Three Brothers so you know what when
amily is a lot a lot bigger now than we
grew up and we grow up there's like a
thousand people in the town so there's a
small group of kids and um my old we're
always sporty like my oldest brother was
kind of lead the way I suppose you know
it was like Cricket touch tennis rugby
whatever and that was kind of all we did
was all summer mom and dad would drive
us around and all winter they' drive us
to rugby and between the three of us um
they were pretty busy parents like a lot
of parents these days are yeah are your
parents tall um my mom is quite tall for
a lady yeah and then um she's got a
couple of tall brothers so the the
height comes from the Ashworth side not
the retallic side that's for sure oh
true so what about your um siblings are
they tall yes I got my um my oldest
brother he's like he was a first five so
that kind of puts into perspective and
he calls himself the practice stroke and
then uh and then my little brother he's
like we're centimeter apart in height in
terms of height true he's tall as well
yeah so when did you get toall when did
you have your gross B I think I was like
um kind of year eight so when you're
year eight you're what 12 12ish I know
when I turned up to high school I um
again follow my oldest brother we went
into crosstitch boys hi his mom was
working to town so she just used to drop
us off and I turned up first day um as a
third former and I was the tallest kid
at high school
so true yeah yeah I say you were real
tall you had a massive gross bit I think
I grew like six Ines and seven months or
something like that and then and then
that was till about the age of you know
like I said 13 14 and then I pretty much
haven't grown again
so that is a massive third forer yeah
you can imagine how far
everyone else I was the third for of
that school so you're basically normal
height going through sort of primary
school not normal height but like
average height in your class were you
yeah I was well I mean I was probably
always like slightly above average
taller and then yeah as of kind of that
year seven year eight kind of year
period I just shot up like you know you
have the classic pencil on the wall at
home and my one just
jumped jumped massively I get the VI
that you were sort of a um skill
skillful back as well maybe a first VI
as well like your brother up until that
gross bear is that probably Fair what
were you I still like think I'm a
skillful back at
time n i was um yeah growing up I was
always I was number eight till I went to
um till I went to cross it boys and I
got chucked in at lock but yeah I think
you know as brothers do play on the lawn
play rugby in the driveway and he was
always trying to step me you know so I
was trying to step back obviously
probably a little bit less coordinated
but yeah how hard was that having that
gross spirit with your coordination and
um I guess getting that body awareness
back again because when you grow have a
gross spiritd that quickly I guess that
can be quite challenging yeah I think
like looking back like at at the time I
probably didn't know exactly like what
the difference you know just it just
happened and that's what it was but um
it wasn't until I kind of got to the end
of high school and
um a couple of coaches said you know
like you just need to grow into your
body just keep doing what you're doing
and working at rugby and like I never
back when we were there at high school
too compared to now we never went to the
gym or anything like that so I guess it
wasn't until I kind of went to Hawks Bay
after leaving school that um got in the
gym and like started to to grow that
skill set and coordination a bit more
and and that's probably kind of where my
Rugby career took off was when I started
to do those things but it wasn't until I
was like the age of 19 that it started
to happen you know yeah so was there any
other sports that you were looking to
you said you played a lot of sports but
were were any of them something that you
thought could be a potential career I
mean basketballers love any tall player
there hips of sports where Hy becomes a
real benefit did you think of any other
sports yeah we were cuz we were day boys
and we obviously for people that don't
know like Amberly is like a 40-minute
drive so I used to play a little bit of
basketball but then basketball used to
be on a Friday night before said day rug
so we kind of see it driving back and
forward we Dro basketball and and focus
on Rugby but um when I was a cross boys
I used to row I was a rower and not that
I ever thought it was a um probably
going to be a career at all but between
rowing and rugby were like the two
sports that took the most seriously you
know I gave up Cricket at about 15 cuz I
took too many daisies in the Outfield
when it became two days you know the
attention span wasn't enough for that so
um yeah rowing and kind of rugby are
definitely the two I took the most
serious true I heard you a bit of a
wizard at um water polo too potentially
because you could touch the bottom of
the pool third for push off the
bottom yeah I mean we like some know
like just gave everything a go really
cuz it was what we did we used to play
water polo and my brother used to play
tennis he used to play tennis and I
guess you know after a while all those
things start to combine and come
together to help you become a b a
sportsman yeah 100% do what do you what
um assets do you um put down to your
rowing how do you think that's helped
you in in your rugby career yeah I think
it probably um yeah like mentally being
able to push yourself and from Roll
you're obviously at times you're in a
boat with four or eight other people but
the kind of training you're doing is a
15 or 16 year old you know sometimes we
were on ugs for for 30 minutes at a time
doing Max efforts and then jumping in a
boat I know um at times we had to get up
and be at K's Reach In Christ Church by
6:00 in the morning so we used to leave
home about 5:00 a.m. go training jump on
our bike bik across town and then go to
school for the day and then jump on the
bike again and go back and roll in the
afternoon so all right like you look
back now and think GE it's like there
was a crazy amount of training for like
a 15 16 year old but I guess it kind of
built that mental resilience yeah built
that massive ticket that you've got at
it's um definitely um helped you
throughout your rugby career yeah I
think like I used to think it would help
what like help my Rugby training for the
winter but I soon learned that like
pushing in a boat doesn't correlate to
running the roads
so yeah I had to start running again
that's for sure yeah so when you got to
the end of um High School yeah you
didn't make the Canter or Crusaders
Academy at the time um what was your
pathway there the the decisions that you
had to we up there
yeah so like kind of had I said like at
school we just used to train twice a
week go playing a Satur day and um grab
a box of years and you know that was it
that was till next week but schoolwise
in like the um can kind of like had a
schools Academy you call it some thing
we go and train twice a week um and
honestly I don't really think it was
going to be rugby was even going to be a
career obviously enjoyed playing rugby
had done it the whole time and left
school and or com to in sth form and
there was no spot in like a pre Academy
or Academy and
um the last three or four years before
that Hawks Bay had had had signed a few
kry players you know like ash Dixon and
Ryan McLoud guys from crushit boys was a
bit of a link between the head of hostel
and and Tom comry yeah and um they asked
if I you know want to go up and have a
look around and I was just going to go
to the potic and cross church and stuff
my engineering apprenti SHP and they
kind of said I think at the time it was
like they signed for like $155,000 and
they would pay for my um pay for me to
go to the poly Tech up there and do the
same course and so me and my dad we flew
up there one day and had a look around
and he was like [__] son I don't know I
don't know how you're going to live on
$155,000 but like you're going to be on
your
own so anyway I was like wow I mean it
saves me paying for my politic and I can
go and earn a little bit of money and
play rugby you know
and yeah me and my older brother we I
think it was early January 2010 yeah we
jumped in the car and drove drove up to
Hawks Bay and got stuck in really far
out how did you live on
15,000 a lot of tuner and
crackers well it still bulked you out
didn't it yeah I um thankfully my um
cousin he they one of them there they
come from HKS Bay one of them was Liv in
napia so I would went lived with him and
his partner there his wife um for about
a year and they would come off a farm so
manag to eat a lot of their food and uh
scrimp by I think you got the
$5,250 student allowance each week
and and then obviously incredibly quick
um growth in your in your game in your
career from there like two years later I
think think yeah you're in the All
Blacks but you've won Super titles you
played New Zealand 20s how did it happen
so quick like yeah obviously play a big
year of
NPC um almost straight
away yeah so obviously like you know in
Hawks Bay the the player pool was
obviously a little bit smaller so we got
Chuck straight into the academy and um
probably someone to rowing like just we
just trained a lot and I hadn't
obviously trained like that before and I
just probably showed like the benefit of
if you're prepared to put in is is what
you get out sort of thing and um we were
in the gym and skills Training Club
training like four four days a week two
sessions and got a got alongside I guess
cuz the smaller kind of player pool we
were alongside the itm cup coaches the
whole time and Tom commentry was um
coaching the Meg P of Peter Russell and
he just kind of see this is this is what
I want from a lock like if you can go do
it I'll give you an opportunity and um
but first Target in the New Zealand on
the 20s so yeah just went about it
really got on the gym training hard and
then um that under 20s year rolled
around and I I guess it gave me a
purpose or like knew exactly how I
wanted to play the game cuz that's what
Tom told me and um and then yeah made
the 20s went to Italy and um yeah it was
like that team was the first experience
of like a professional semi-professional
team and um the players that are in it I
think there's one that hasn't played
professional rugby so it like shows you
the stand of the people around and I
guess you just like start to love it
when you get a taste of it and
um came back and I was playing a little
bit of Club rugby and then one of the
Hawks Bay Locks was sick during the week
and um Tom said oh you're either
starting or you're not and uh not going
to play and then the Ross Kennedy was
his name and in the end he was sick and
I got chucked in the starting
team and in into it true how did you
feel did you feel um radial um I think I
was like I remember being confident like
like I'm ready I'm ready to go like I
want to have a crack yeah um but at the
same time like you look back now I was
just running around chasing rocks like
probably thought absolutely
nothing I don't know about that cuz I
you kept your starting spot for the rest
of the season didn't you well so there
was and then play one more game against
ockland and then the start the next
season was like started pretty much all
of them but um yeah it was I guess a
sharp learning curve but at the same
time it's like I appreciate it because I
got the opportunity to experience it and
from experience you learn you know and
um sometimes like people have to wait a
while and in different clubs and
franchises but for me it was like I just
wanted to get out there and that's how I
become a better rugby player was by
doing it so I was thankful for the
opportunity yeah and even I remember
talking to Mike kman the great moo about
um your mindset your training mindset he
always ad always admired how You' um he
said when you first got there you
couldn't catch a kickoff um to to save
yourself every day after training you'd
be out there catching kickoffs catching
kick offs catch and kickoffs even though
you're no good at it but like after
maybe a month you were now unreal at
catching kickoffs so just that mindset
of being able to practice something even
though you weren't that good at it I
know a lot of guys always have that sort
of embarrassment especially guys of
practicing something they're not good at
CU they don't want to be judged but you
obviously had no issue with that yeah I
didn't really have an issue with like I
always got told too like you know you're
making a mistake you learn from it and I
guess that kind of that philosophy but I
also like when I'm when I moved to Hawks
Bay I was 18 like I didn't really have
any mates I knew no one in Hawks Bay
apart from my cousin like I was probably
a little bit of a loner but so like all
I do is go and train you know
like and and I guess I did that drive
like I was there had gone there with
that opportunity and I didn't want to
miss it so I yeah tried do the extra
school work and gym work to to become a
b rugby player so cool and was it your
relationship with Dave reenie from the
20s that yet got you to the Chiefs in
the end um was no we had um Cowboy Anam
as a coach he would came in after R but
the connection was um Tom so I remember
the time he played that full season in
my team Cup and the Hurricanes had set
to me um I think it was like a wider
training Squad spot and then maybe one
or two years full afterwards oh yeah and
then Tom obviously got the chief's job
alongside Dave and he said to me one day
he's like man we'll give you a full SWOT
a full contract two years you come to
the chiefs of me and
um yeah I guess I I was always going to
take that over a wider training Squad
and and then having Tom and a couple
couple of players that I played 20s with
in the chief Squad um it was it was the
option for me m and straight away you're
in there you're winning Super Rugby
titles it was it was all too easy for
you yeah it was I look back there and a
little bit of hindsight like how good a
group and how not how easy it was but
like I now realize how hard it is to do
yeah from from the years
afterwards um but yeah it was kind of
similar like a I turned up to the Chiefs
and Craig Clark and Roman Graham with
only two estab like two um established
locks from the years before and it was
me and Michael F Fitz J from M War I
yeah but um Roman Graham had headbed
someone in the in
the what do they call it NPC like final
so it was there was only four locks so
there was and three available so one of
us had to start and same thing I was
like oh well this is this is an
opportunity like you don't want to miss
out on on so just got stuck in really
how'd you find the step up oh well there
the time me and Sam Kane and Shane
cleever and uh my wife we all lived
together and like we would just come
home and sit on the couch fall asleep
pretty much
like she she sometimes jokes about how
like we just come home and say nothing
to her and just sit there and watch TV
go to
bed well you're still together now she
obviously loved it yeah she hung in
there like thankfully it's still painful
chair probably but it's probably better
than the painful
chair yeah like and at the time was um
the chiefs were building their training
facility so we were training at a high
school and we're we're on the bike
biking everywhere training like smashing
down walls
and yeah we it was some hot summers back
hot summer training that's for sure yeah
and by all accounts the intensity of the
trainings for the Chiefs back then were
always I'm pretty heated especially on
the I think it was the Thursday or the
two day before a game um session always
sounded like it was basically a game for
the guys who weren't playing all the all
the starters to go to go at it was that
about right yeah pretty pretty much yeah
like same thing like it was kind of my
my first two years and I didn't know any
different but now I look back and been
like jeez we like the amount of fighting
that went on at training and not and not
because like we didn't like each other
just because how competitive and was in
there and pretty much said like you
don't lose a one-on-one battle like
that's how you lose on Sat day so boys
were just competing and getting stuck in
I remember like my first preseason
somewhere in there got chucked into a a
line out and um ran Graham obviously
like I he couldn't play so he would just
like pulled me out of the year and I
couldn't sit the allall in the year
pulled me out and Tom was like do it
again he did the exact same thing to me
and he's like br
out I was like oh well if he it's good
enough for him to do it then I'm going
to do it you know so I pulled him out of
the air and then thing all
pushing next minute you're headbutting
everyone is that where you got your love
for niggle was cuz were you always a
niggly player even coming through school
or was it around that Chiefs time where
you learned a bit more of a nigle craft
yeah it was like it was all from those 2
or 3 years I think like at school I
would have said peep you know just and
then just worked out like if someone's
having a bad day you might as well
reinforce it if it's going to help you
win you know
yeah oh that's good stuff so you're grow
and then at the end of that season
you're you're starting in the final
aren't you yeah I think I um I think I
might have started all but one one game
that that season like yeah yeah just cuz
we lost first game versus hollanders and
um and I think we went on one everyone
and I don't know way like just you 20
years old got nothing to worry about you
just week in week out just trying to
perform and it it's pretty uh
uncomplicated back then yeah it's crazy
he to think where you came from around
not making the academy two years earlier
then two years later you're starting in
a um Super Rugby final it's pretty
crazy yeah
yeah um I've thought about it a few
times like it it took a I don't know how
like I don't really know how it happened
but like it I still think now I was like
pretty pretty lucky to do that and even
made the all backs when I did and have
the career it's um it's been pretty
special yeah so it was on the back of
that um super rugby season you make the
All Blacks is that right yeah I think it
was around um the middle of that first
year they had like a camp of I can't
remember how many players 38 40 players
of they might um might pack or we're
looking at and got called to that and
then um yeah we played the
blues just uh just turned 21 that week
had gone out and had a few beers midweek
and then we played the blues at North
Harbor and come off this come off the
field and um Darren Shan was in the
tunnel and said you that you made the
All Blacks so had to cancel my 21st
birthday party and play a test match
instead oh true so did you have a big
21st lined up all your mates had come
from everywhere yeah I like since I'd
gone to Hawks Bay I hadn't really been
home that much and yeah I had like was
going to have it back in Christ Church
and um had my 21st and then yeah I had
to send out a message a couple weeks
before it saying sorry party's
off so where was you um d uh debut was
in 2012 ver Island at um Eden Park oh
yeah and um yeah there was me nugi and
uh Julian S all debuted the same night
um against against him far and what what
are you feeling were you were you
starting or Off the
Bench it was like a similar scenario
we're like sitting in our rooms and P
there back then Steve Hansen would ring
ring you and it wasn't um not everyone
had cell phones even back then and he so
he'd ring the room that your like your
hotel room be like come see me yeah and
uh I was in I think I was in a room with
Sam Kane like just in there and he and
he got the
call go see him you know and um anyway I
went back to my room I I'll just go wait
in my room see it happens and it never
ran and I didn't sleep at all like oh
[__] am I going to be playing like team
gets named and um I was probably more
worried about doing the hucker and not
not stuffing that up than the actual
game but youone says that the anxiety of
a hucker on your debut sounds like it
just takes all your um thought away from
playing the game yeah it was a few years
ago as um and we're in Perth like around
the co time and I end up kept in one
game I was still watching the hucker on
YouTube like on the way to the game
because I didn't want to be out the
front and stuff the hacker up you know
like the hacker on YouTube must have
millions of views mainly from the All
Blacks themselves just refreshing their
memory of what actually what the actions
are any they you should put on their
website a revenue
maker so your debut went well though I
think so it was a bit like um a bit like
it cup you know like it was just so fast
and before you knew it was halftime and
um and then I think I played maybe 60
Minutes roughly all up but yeah things
just happen so quick at T match level it
probably took takes you 15 old games to
get used to it that's why I was always
reckon like judging someone on three or
four three or four opportunities at test
matches is tough you know it's like it's
so much faster than Super Rugby and
people are stronger it it it does take a
while to a that but um and also the
speed of the game is just so much
quicker but it was uh it's a special
moment like playing the Eden Park in
front of a crowd New Zealand crowd and
the Irish um and we W and we won you
know so it was some pretty fall memories
yeah that's interesting to hear more
about the speed than the physicality
like often hear people talk around the
you know the intensity of the collisions
at test match but you feel like it's the
speed of the game where it's just
everything's just so so much quicker
yeah everything's just so much quicker
like you just don't have time to react
you know
like put you put Reco your Ary against
me like speed wise like if the off like
you you just can't C you can't I can't
catch it no way you know so like when
you've got backs the backs that quick
all seven of them on the field or
whatever it is you know like it it is so
much quicker there's no doubt about that
yeah what was the key for you to be able
to adapt to that speed or handle that
speed um and
yeah um I guess like you you aerobically
like you become used to it like I always
like first test of the year No Matter
first year or seventh year always the
hardest day like you're just blowing it
takes out of you can us to it again just
get in the shower after the test match
just be an absolute wreck you know like
physically cuz it's just taking it out
of you but um I think like you you start
to read the game and and try and like
anticipate where where things are going
to end up like where the ball's going to
end up I always found like for me anyway
that was like a a big part of my game of
like anticipating where the next rck was
going to be so you're not running a big
u-shaped line just you're trying to make
the straightest line possible and and
save as much energy you know and um a
couple years later from your debut and
you named the best player in the world
what's that like what's that feeling
like not many people get to experience
that yeah especially that young I think
you're the youngest ever too still are
I don't know I was actually we like we
were in Wales and like been to go watch
a movie on the day off and it was I
don't know 10 or so of us and then
Jerome cono come up to me I like oh
congratulations how good and I was like
what are you talking about and he's like
oh you're nominated for player of the
year and I was
like it just wasn't even on my radar to
be fair like yeah I yeah like you know
some people can obviously set goals like
they want to be that's what they want to
achieve do this but it was just one of
those things that came from playing
within a good team and I guess like I
was playing well and yeah it wasn't
something I was looking to do put it
that way but um yeah it's pretty awesome
to be able to say that I won that yeah
so what what's that like you go to the
awards you don't know if you've won or
not uh I when I I received it was um I
Steve Henson said he knew two or three
days before I knew but were just on the
field and then I've seen them like
running out this like a background you
know with sponsors and World rugby and
stuff on it and then cple boys like you
want it you want
it
and got presented the uh the trophy
plaque thing just that on the field and
yeah it's obviously pretty pretty happy
and stok so it was a big big night that
kind of entailed from the back of that
yeah I bet M and like you're playing
with Legends of the game at this point
like all the all some of the biggest
names of New Zealand ragby are in your
team at that side is that a little bit
was that a little bit awkward like I
think what you you were 22 or something
and
um you've come on the scene pretty
pretty quickly and now you're voted as a
better player by the greatest player in
the world yeah I don't remember it being
awkward to be fair I remember like just
being like being happy and saying I
remember Richie saying like no one can
ever take that away from you and like
Well Done um that's cool I think that's
what makes them like so good such good
players and people was like it was it
was like not that I know just saw any
jealousy or was like dope to do it you
know and um like to say like I remember
walking on that bus and looking down the
back and at times and how awesome it was
that you got to play with players of
that caliber and like T Legends of of
the game yeah and then the following
year you're off to the 2015 Rugby World
Cup as the best player in the world um
how was it going into that Rugby World
Cup yeah it was um like not the say that
like made me cocky or like I don't know
but like I guess in the back of head you
had kind of had that
expectation like oh you just been named
that I remember Aaron crud saying oh
you've gone a year too early
like should have been well year 15 not
14 but um I think the the the ER of and
the the all whack team and the
performances and the results that got
like it was just it was a dream really
like you had all that experience there
some of those guys were on their fourth
world cup and the learnings in terms of
the leadership and
preparation that was put into it um I
think we were far more prepared like
going into 15 than we were 2019 in
hindsight and I think a lot of that
comes down to like those players that
had been there for such a long time and
knew exactly what was needed and what
needed to be done you know and you and
you look at sort of the World Cup teams
have been successful they generally are
in that older age recet do you think
that's a big part of it those guys who
have been in it been in the moments
they've experienced so many different um
games and they know how to handle those
those preure
situations yeah definitely I think like
kind of how I said before like it's like
getting used to a getting used to t a
normal test match but like being in a
World Cup playoff there is no there's no
greater pressure um like even the France
final week like it's it's not a breeze
in terms of your training week but
there's just the mental pressure of
being going in there to perform and you
know you either walking out of they a
hero or walking away with a silver medal
and um I think that arena is is the
greatest pressure that I've experienced
had a rugby player and by being there
only makes you more confident before I
think what game's been the one that
you've been the most nervous going into
out of all of
them um it's a good question probably
the probably the 15 final oh yeah yeah
yeah like again there like obviously
World Cup final gets no bigger
and then the first World Cup final like
you don't know what to expect and US
versus the Wes and twick them they
beating us earlier in the year for the
rugby Championship yeah um and the same
time just reforming for like all those
guys who are playing their last test
match that obviously helped so much over
the last last three years before that
well it's pretty cool you've been to
three Rugby World Cups you've got a a
gold silver and a bronze so you've got
the whole table
um what Memories stand out um from each
of them I guess I guess you've spoken
about the 2015 one what about the
2019 yeah 19 was like an interesting one
in terms of like I personally feel like
15 like we were just so well prepared
and we knew exactly how we were playing
our game um I'm not sure what how much
you've heard but like we even in the
early pool stages like we we won quite
convincingly but we trained probably
harder during the week to build towards
the playoffs and then I know it was not
like the perfect recipe but like there
the French and and um and Cardiff where
they've beaten us before and then to
play the Wes that have beaten Us in the
final um whereas 19 we're probably a
little bit more cluttered in terms of
how we were going to play and and have
our understanding and um again like like
I say we didn't have we had experience
of World Cups but not probably like the
of the the one of the team with the
squad before um so yeah it's it's it was
I'm not going to say the one that got
away but I felt like the French one we
we were better prepared in England and
France than we were in Japan what do you
remember about um the recent French
games yeah it was um was some awesome
rugby to be a part of like I think in
terms of playing start to France is
probably right up there one of the B
stadiums is it true like in the in the
opening game when obviously we got
beaten like I've never heard an
atmosphere like that before the crowd
singing and the people and just probably
the halation from the French people you
know then it was the other way around
four weeks later when we beat the Irish
and um yeah it's it's like it still
hurts a lot to be fair I think you know
from we pretty much did all we could
with you know obviously with the cards
and and playing with 4 men for a long
period of time but um yeah again it's
like Jee what could it been I suppose
yeah so when you lose when you lose the
red card and you're playing with 40 men
have you are you still really confident
um that you can get the job done yeah
well when we played the um sou Africa
and tockenham like what 10 weeks before
the world before that game like we play
there and we had a similar scenario so
we'd actually put in heaps of time like
we went to Germany after that game and
probably for a day and a half a training
just recreate a scenarios recards yellow
cards different players out what we
would do so when it happened it like
wasn't a shock cuz we were kind of
prepared for it I guess at the end of
the day like it two of the or two of the
best teams going at it there's not much
room there's not much opportunity and we
just didn't quite get the opportunities
to get across the line and they were
able to squeeze it squeeze the score the
points on us you know yeah oh you you
watch that world cap and you just
realize how such small margins um Define
especially those big games I guess
you're on the right side of it um with
isand which was probably one of the best
games I've watched um as a spectator but
um even in that final like such small
margins are deciding these games yeah
and like we know like a game versus um
sou Africa to Island like there a bit
more it's a bit more like a bit more
opportunistic like there tries to be
scored and people are playing attacking
whereas West Africa like you know what
you're going to get and the opportunity
to score because defensively I think
Steven Steve Detroit made 27 tackles in
a test match like it's unbelievable you
know like I don't know enough I've ever
seen anyone make that many tackles in a
test match like so it shows how hard and
how well they are defensively to break
yeah they were hard tackles too they
flying do you find that South African
and still um probably the most physical
pack um to play against yeah I think
they still they and the the way they you
know they play the game there's not much
footwork from the affords they're just
all about running over top you and they
have they obviously train and get in the
gym to to build that size whereas from a
New Zealand point of view we're like you
know want to use our footwork want to
use our skill so it's it's it's like a
clash of probably the two different
styles I know when we paid them for two
or 3 years and they're just box kicking
and it's like from a playing point of
view it's not much fun to play against
either like from for for a style that
like to play anyway but it's it's what
makes the game it is I suppose yeah man
it's fascinating cool to get an Insight
um from from your seat uh and I guess
another big sort of all black test match
that you've been involved in was the um
Lions tour when they came here um what
do you remember about that
one yeah it
was it was it's like one of those
opportunities like when you're playing
as National Rugby that that you want to
be a part of and um
after the World Cup like it was all
you're looking forward to was when the
Lions come and be in position to be a to
play them um again like one in one in
ockland quite easy and and then go down
to
Wellington
um the one moment that like sticks out
me is like when they scored in the
corner fwer scores in the corner like I
don't know I was just like coming from
the inside like and I knew it was going
to happen but I just wasn't fast enough
to get there Dy kind of half got him and
I miss them and the scores like again
just those moments and it would have had
the had the thing sealed up and again it
come down to a like a r call at the end
of the third match that rightly or
wrongly that was decided the the um the
series I suppose and I would have loved
to say that I had one over the a series
over the lines that's for sure yeah
right and it or what is it every 12
years um don't come around very often do
they no there's a thing like if you're
lucky to fall within the the rotation
the 12 years that's one thing and then
to obviously say you beat them um but
yeah like when the amount of support I
remember we were in Oakland for that
first test match and the amount of
support is just walking around the
streets and it's pretty special to be a
part of and I think like in terms of
like the game it needs to needs to stay
around you know for what it does for
obiously the economy of countries but
the experience of the rugby and for the
fans it's something pretty special yeah
what do you your thoughts on a um
southern hemisphere type lions um group
so combining the the southern hemisphere
teams how do you reckon that would go I
reckon it would be pretty interesting to
be honest like you you get a Regin the
max of like the team the team you know
like it it' be a tough one to pick but
if you played if you did a similar thing
like you had kind of two squads and
played a a midweek here and a and a sday
test and you could pick and choose like
I reckon generate plenty of interest and
I'm sure it's something like look how
many boys love playing for the
barbarians like I guess it's something
similar like it's a good way to meet
people and and play with people you're
normally playing against have you played
for the barbarians I haven't I have't um
in uh
2020 Andy Ellis and um Dan Carter were
at coob and they were going to go play
and Andy said Robbie Robbie Deans was
coaching and he said would you be
interested in going and I I said to Andy
I I'll pretty keen and then Co hit the
world so it never progressed further so
um if anyone from the Barbarian
Association is listening I would love to
do it at some point you'd be one of the
great barbarians I
reckon just never I never had much
interest to me to like fly home from an
India tour and jump on a plane and fly
all the way back to Europe but like from
where I'm at now i' definitely love to
give it a go yeah and and you speak
about Japan like where you are now um
your decision to take your sabatical
um after that Rugby World Cup how hard
was that decision or was there offers
anywhere else that you were weighing up
uh in that in that time not really I
think the probably the the only decision
I was contemplating was if I was to come
here and stay and not go back to New
Zealand or if I would cuz at the time I
had talked to Kobe and then I pretty
much said to New Zealand Rugby like I'm
going to go and if you want me to come
back like I I would be Keen but if not
I'll I'll stay you know over there and
they said that they were Keen to have me
come back afterwards um but like it was
from just from a refreshing point of
view in terms of coming to a new culture
and a new club new coaches different
ideas um yeah I think it was like
massively important to get him being
able to get through to the end of um the
next World Cup that's for sure yeah
that's interesting so you feel like it's
a really important um play from New
Zealand rugby to keep the sabatical and
give these guys who have been in the
same environments you know doing the
same training same same training grounds
Etc to have an experience come back
refresh and get a bit more time out of
them I think so in
like when I came here last time like we
our team was we were on a on fire sort
of thing like and at times we were
beating people by like 80 90 points and
I understand that that's like um that's
not always deal but now the the
competition is getting so much harder
here like they changed the passport rule
so you don't need to qualify for a
Japanese passport you just need to spend
four years in the country so there's a
lot of a lot more foreign players
playing in the competition so the rugby
quality has like improved massively but
from a mental side of the game like that
was the biggest refresher for me um just
mentally and I was actually like really
mentally hungry to get back to New
Zealand and start playing again and I
guess I knew i' had the break and I
wanted to prove myself again if that
makes sense yeah and how hard was that
to come back um especially I guess the
physicality of the game especially Super
Rugby or International Rugby um from the
Japan League which has probably played
especially um that first time you went
over there was definitely played a
little bit differently yeah I think it's
probably the one thing that I wouldn't
do again is come to Japan and go
straight back to t r like from from the
the leap of intensity and physicality
and looking back was probably just it
took me a little bit to get used to
again and also maybe didn't help like
with all the stuff that was going on
around off the field with the oacs and
coaches and um stuff like I I talked to
Jas Ryan before I left and I said like
for anyone that's doing it you just got
to install confidence back in them that
they still good enough to do it and um
and still play at this level when they
come back I think that's what took the
longest was just finding the confidence
to be the the player again rather than
um anything physically and you mentioned
all that sort of background drama like
how much involvement do you have in
there are you big part of the leadership
group do you do you jumping on all those
sort of decisions and meetings um I've
been in the leadership group of the old
since
2014 I think it
was youngest ever in the leadership
group too I've seen a few leadership
meetings um oh it's not it's not me like
I sorry in terms of the leadership like
around the team and stuff then yeah I
enjoy it but all the stuff that goes on
like in terms of the coaching
appointments and all that it's not me
like I I stay out of that you know
it's and there's no way to hide from it
when it got to the spot it did around
the coaches like it it becomes a
distraction and for me it's keeping
things as simple as possible
to perform on satday um is what works
best for me yes so what's the key to or
we often hear about the All Blacks
leadership group and um how incredible
they are I guess like what's the key to
that leadership group being being so
good yeah there's probably a few
elements and like they always say and it
always comes back to being the best
performers on the field um like
obviously experience in the test Arena
helps but the stuff that people don't
see is probably all the learning in
terms of around leadership and and
Leadership qualities that we do like in
the offseason we would meet three times
um a year for a good day in choss
Oakland and have leadership coaches
there and and talk about things from the
previous T season that we would do
different um at times done stuff with
like New Zealand Police around
communication and and making decisions
under PR pressure and and focusing on
like what's important and what's not and
I think um uh like what makes up some of
the best leaders just from learning this
is like communication you know is
knowing what to say and how to get it
across your peers because everything
understands things differently yeah and
what's it like for new guys coming in
cuz that's one I always always talk to
guys who you know when they go into the
all black environment feel very
uncomfortable feel like they don't
deserve to be there in their head but
there you always seem to be made um
pretty welcome from the start like
what's the key to that I think it's like
pretty much what you said is like if
you've been there while or an older
players like just making people feel
comfortable and be themselves I mean but
when uh when I made in like you had Cory
Jane and Izzy D like the two of the
biggest jok is just like taking the piss
out of everyone but then you had the old
boys like Richie and kibi that would you
know when they need to draw a hard line
would and yeah I think um yeah that's
key and obviously the coaches play a
massive a massive part of them
environment of working alongside the
players and making them feel comfortable
but if you got people pretending or or
trying to be something that they're not
then it's it's hard to then ask them to
express themselves on a Saturday night
you know yeah on and off the
field which I hear you go very well
at both I'm getting too old now well it
gets harder right oh it
does and I'm hesitant to bring this one
up but the cheap final um last year like
you spoke about the two Super Rugby
titles you get at the start of your
career it's all too easy and then you
have I guess a relatively rough patch um
for a decent period of time that last
season um no doubt the best team in the
comp throughout the competition
basically up until the final and
arguably we're even the better team that
night but um what do you what do you
remember about that season and how tough
was that
one yeah I've only just um I've only
just paid my debts for that final as of
last week who was that to well when was
when it come to coob touched on Andy
Ellis was here and when we went back he
was back in New Zealand I was back and
and he text me and said oh one and we
put a dozen rewinds on the Crusaders
Chiefs and I was like yeah obviously I'm
backing back in the team back in the
team I'm playing for and let's just say
I've paid him more dozens of wi that
he's paid me over the last three
years but um yeah we obviously had one
on the final and um I've seen them twice
I think he goes where's my where's my
dozen wine and I said I'm not over it
you mate like when I'm over it I I'll
pay
you and obviously being a new year in
2024 now I miss him I said mate your
wi's on the way I can let it go
now I'm finally over it um but yeah like
I say it was it was just one of those
years where everything kind of clicked
for us
and I think like credit to the Chiefs
like and Don and the organization like
they had a had a plan around like when
they had recruited players and like I
don't think there was many players that
in that kind of match day 23 come the
final that least didn't have a couple
years Super experience and as you know
now like experience in and time in the S
with super is not what it used to be so
having that Squad that had been together
for a good couple of years and and
players that were playing so well like
when you've got new guys like Amon and
Sean Stevenson like players like that
they're coming through Leaps and Bounds
and playing so well it energizes the
squad
and um yeah it was again it was just
like when you you know when you're
winning and you're playing well like the
weeks become easy and yeah we could like
in the language that Don had started to
use like he was like this is our year
you know like this is this is the year
that we've been building towards and ter
of about getting our Squad to where we
were and and and still confidence in US
yeah and then how hard do it post at
when it when it doesn't quite end up
being that year yeah it uh it it hurts
it hurts like it's just not the same
really like your whole your whole year
and especially like for where I was and
where weby weby was in terms of a player
and the boys like that we knew this was
our last opportunity and and we put the
work in to to put ourselves in that
position of been in the final and um we
we want we knew from previous years how
hard it was to travel in terms when you
come to playoff so we knew we wanted to
to get that top spot so that we could
play at home to give ourselves the best
opportunity and like I say we we did
everything we set out to do except for
that final hurdle and um yeah it's still
like knowing that come post that game
didn't I haven't been back to the Chiefs
facility since um and no and that still
like you walked out of there and fell
just short it's still uh still eats away
yeah that's for sure do could do you see
yourself get Hing back there at any
point or was that you definitely done at
the chiefs no that that's me definitely
done I think
um like by our own choice the last
couple of years uh my wife and our two
daughters have lived down in napia and I
lived in Hamilton by myself like for
Super Rugby
and the time of just doing that around
school and stuff was was better for us
but um it sort of not not took its toll
but took its toll but I was definitely
ready to to give it up I think similar
to the All Blacks you know like I knew
I'd had had my time there and I don't
see myself going back to play for the
all black so I've got three seasons here
and um we'll see what happens but
otherwise we'll we'll we call Nate home
now so not having a franchise base in
the town is also a good reason not to go
back
that that's interesting because that
that's a big commitment e to obviously
play apply a trade um away from your
family um especially on your days off
and I guess you I know your would be
hard for your wife as well to have to do
that by by herself so um it's definitely
a big commitment to do that playing in a
different franchise to where your family
are living yeah I mean it's it was um I
wouldn't say hard but like it definitely
had its challenges around like with a
five and a seven year old like the um
but we just thought it was better in
terms of being around some family um
back in Hawks Bay and we didn't want to
have to move um move them school every
six months so um that yeah that was that
was what we did but um yeah it's it's
definitely been nice like it almost felt
a little bit weird to come to uh Japan
and just be around the kids and 24/7
again like it was like I actually get to
hang around and have some fun with them
rather than just coming home for a night
and then disappearing early in the
morning again yeah oh that's cool and
and you mentioned you at Kobe for 3
years um how was your body yeah the here
for yeah we straight into this first one
then two more so the body's actually in
really good shape like I don't I
dislocated my shoulder like four or five
years ago and apart from that touchwood
like I have no other sort of niggles um
like in a one of the physios here comes
from New Zealand does a couple of weeks
he goes man you're actually in good
shape eh and I like yeah I am I feel
like I am it takes a little bit older it
takes a little bit longer to recover as
you get older like you know it's not you
don't bounce back quite as well on a
Monday morning but in terms of the body
it's actually in a good spot and do you
see yourself retiring on your own terms
post that um Co contract or do you would
you potentially go go again go till the
wheels fall
off that's that's what everyone says
that is like just hanging there cuz
going to work every day he not as good
as going to
training uh I think I'd probably like to
stay a little bit longer than um than
the three seasons if it works out um if
not um yeah we'll head back to nap year
I always white Crockett um obviously as
you know him probably pretty well but
like I thought the way he did it like he
went back and played for tesman immersed
himself back into a semi normal not rug
life is a good way to do it so um if
that was the way to be I hope maybe if
they wanted me like go play a season or
two for the mag pi and and work your way
back into it rather than go to cold
turkey it's kind of um a little bit
daunting like knowing rugby is all I've
ever known and not kind of held down a
full-time job so don't really have too
much planned post rugby at the moment
that's for sure yeah what what are you
thinking there or um just no idea would
you get into
coaching um it's a good question like oh
I've changed my mind plenty of times
like what I think I'm going to do and
like as life goes like you end up in
different spots or like different
things I feel like I don't know if I
would be a coach like in terms of maybe
a super R coach I could be like maybe it
team cup I just feel like I've had the
best kind of experience from learning
some some of the best coaches in the
world for a long time and like whether I
can get that across the young players is
a different question but um yeah I
haven't made any too many final
decisions um around what I'll do yet
like post rugby because like I say youd
actually don't know when it's going to
finish do you yeah and I guess other
thing is especially with coaching is if
you want to settle in Hawks Bay um how
long would you would you be there for
are you going to continue chasing that
sort of dream of being that coach and
moving around every time you get your
next contract Etc so I'm guessing you
want to be pretty settled in Hawks Bay
with your family and and what your kids
grow up there that's uh probably one
like downside of of having a being a a
professional rugy player like you always
want the next best thing or improve
yourself to challenge yourself more but
um yeah I'm like I we've obviously moved
around a little bit over the last 10 12
years so I'm
pretty pretty s on getting back to Haw
Bay and just settling down there and and
uh and staying put for a while right how
good J would be good to see you back out
there for the mag Pi don't have a few
mag pie pans excited I went back there
for um a few weeks
uh two years ago like around the injury
and it was good fun like I hope I'm not
sure what the future of it looks like in
terms of everything that's going on you
rugby but like it is it's pretty awesome
to be a part of you know yeah you would
have some good times there but mate
water a Korea we will gez we're gone
we're gone real good we we'll go through
some questions here we've gone to the
Instagram plenty plenty have come in for
you mate most of them are around your
nickname oh everyone's fascinated with
the nickname guzzler how'd you get
it well they like people ask me like
what's and they of f like drinking on my
cars but like it actually got nothing to
do with me so when I turned up to Chiefs
in 2012 my cousin Callum who had been
there for the last two years and that
was his nickname it was guzzler and they
were like and obviously some of those
boys are still there they're like you're
exactly like [__] like you're just a
guzer like
him and I was like what is this like
what is this nickname and we both like
look pretty similar I suppose to like it
just got I just got stuck with it there
but it's actually his
nickname how did he get it was
his I think it might have been a
question he answered around someone
and Oh I thought it was going to be a
massive diesel capacity to neck one but
no that's what I mean I'm like it's
probably a bit of a let down for lot of
people I just
got okay one ham and cheese Story
please what is that it's from Brad Weber
so so it's usually good he comes in with
good questions usually old bread
wether
oh L there we uh preseason game like
over a malula bar or something like this
like pre Super Rugby and um we having a
few beers like a bit of team bonding
going on and anyway we uh me and Mitch
Brown loose for the CH we decided to
have like one-on-one scrums cuz
we and anyway I got absolutely folded
and ended up sitting on top of the
toasting
machine and they were like you just got
ham and cheese give me another
toasty I still recently pushed early
but I haven't L that down especially
from wey that's for sure that's good
stuff MCH Brown loves it to he's always
he's always gave me another chance and
then he buckled me again
so oh good stuff okay next one uh if you
could pick one Northern Hemisphere
player all time to play with who would
it
be oh that's a good
question um all
time probably the first one that comes
to mind is Johnny Wilkinson there oh
yeah yeah I mean like got probably just
like we my age and like watch him at
those World Cups and how good a player
he was his left foot like
we were obviously not Le foot kickers
but used to go and imitate his kicking
style and down at the Rugby Club and
stuff so I'll probably yeah I'd love to
play alongside Johnny Wilkinson mate you
and him would have had a dream
[Laughter]
combo kicking kicking gos
left okay next one what's been the
hardest moment for you during your
career to deal
with compared to a lot of players I feel
like I haven't had a lot of a lot of
adversity you know like yeah I haven't I
haven't um I haven't never really been
dropped I haven't been dropped from the
All Blacks I haven't been dropped from
the cheese I hadn't lost the
contract um but like and the probably
the hardest thing I had to deal with was
and it wasn't even really that hard to
be honest but when I dislocated my
shoulder like heading towards a World
Cup but again like I I never had surgery
from it um I just rehabed it and it and
it stayed in place so I I'm not going to
say anything was really a massive
challenge um compared to what some the
cards that some players have dealt with
you know that's crazy he like what do
you put that down to um firstly the lack
of injuries and obviously you haven't
been dropped that's down to just being
so good but um it's incredible to have
as little setbacks as you have
throughout such a such a long career
yeah I I don't know I guess it's just
good luck of some of them uh I like it I
don't know like some things are just
like you in conversation that you pick
out I always Mike cron telling me when
I'd only been in the orw for a couple
years he's like not a lot of people not
a lot of people stay here without being
dropped and I was like well what do you
mean and he's like you know some people
come in here young but they'll be
dropped for a squad or two and then I
always just like just stuck in my head
like as as motivation you know like you
finish a finish a year and go back home
and be training by yourself with your
mates and I just always think like I
don't want to be that guy I don't want
to be one of those ones that has one or
two good years and then gets the wobbles
and comes back and I know just like
little comments like that have just
always stuck with me in the back of my
mind you know that's awesome it's
obviously paid off because man never
being dropped that's that's that's got
to be a stat first player to never be
dropped from any team ever I don't know
I think I remember when he said it I
think he said Richie and Dan were like
the only two and this was this was like
2014 and I was like that's pretty
impressive like I don't want to be one
of those guys I don't want to be someone
that happens to like through my own
decisions you know like yeah
yeah that's cool love that okay hardest
person to go up against that line out
time probably like probably the three
Crusader locks that I played against
most Sam Scott and Luke Romano like you
think you know what how team's going to
defend and then you come up against them
and they change everything you planned
for that week's
changed changed and you got to think of
ways around them like they they
definitely switched on especially I
remember playing with cards with Luke
Romano like he is unbelievable memory
and then that's what he takes him to his
line out you know he remembers moves she
did two years ago I like I don't even
remember that mate
like um I remember playing ver vers vior
matfield I think we were I was it was
Chiefs versus the Bulls and I was like
just called myself he was standing right
beside me and I was like I'm going to
just see if I can went the line out
right beside him and he picked me picked
it off
so he was pretty quick as well sh
learning call Sharp learning C don't
call line out for yourself right side
but the
mfield oh good stuff K and what's the
story behind the tri celebration few one
too actually if you love that one um
when I well when I went to Hawks Bay and
then ended up moving out of my cousin's
place and um flatting with a couple of
guys I played for like M Rugby Club is
in Hawks Bay um Central and uh that was
just like the tri celebration there it
was just like the rock on throw it up
and then when I made made it to I think
I was going I made it to the MEAP they
like you know if you score or try you
better make sure you do the
celebration and it's just stuck you know
like go put up a salute to the rock
music that I like and the bog out
there just carried on did you did you do
it when you scored the I think you won
um Tri of the year one year didn't you
with that big dummy did you do it for
that try I think I might have done it
even before I scored the scored the try
I was like couldn't believe my luck when
they bet on the
dummy right what a try that
was Glory
Days okay good stuff um next one which
Chiefs player did you square up with the
most at
training I don't know there's probably
no one in particular like like touched
on earlier like in those um early days
it was like just what it was you know
like yeah boys just getting stuck into
each other I remember times like Roman
Graham absolutely fled and hicker Elliot
Josh hle miss him like it it was just
the way we trained and it was like if
you don't want to lose you had to do
what you had to do to
win anyone you would just happy to go
after
anyone sounds like my nightmare on first
day Sean Stevenson just get stuck
in try to W me
up okay um what' you say to P
[Laughter]
Mani I said what was
reported what did he say did he did he
invite back no he said nothing he
said but like I guess he like we're
talking about getting stuck into each
other and when they when they beat us in
Wellington and um in that series like he
was just into us on the field like just
spraying us left right and Center yeah
and like I said like I I enjoy it and
when you're having your day then you let
you know but I'm definitely going to
give it back when we're having our day
and what better moment than uh that one
right there after the penalty that's for
sure oh it's crack up okay um how did
Brody bulk up how did I bulk up I don't
know if I've ever bulked up up
heav how heavy are you now you must be
like what 120 yeah I was at the World
Cup I was
um but when we like I didn't probably
allude to it earlier but when I left
High School I was like 128 kgs 128 were
you oh F right and like we didn't go to
the gym so like it was all just weight
like out of shape you know and like I
didn't really used to jump in the line
out cuz
obviously
no one on our team went to I think Owen
Franks was like 3 years in front of me
at school when he was the only one at
school that used to lift weights like no
one in my year lifted weights
so um for people that know skinfolds out
there the first time I got skinfold
which I didn't even know what good folds
were yeah I asked her I said oh what was
it and she was like oh you're
227 yeah and I said I turned around and
S to her oh is that any good and she was
like
no if I can confirm it is
not currently Scott skinfold maybe a
week ago I think I was 83 if that puts
into perspective oh wow and have you
been basically that range your whole
career around 83 227s M yeah yeah
sometimes I've been the 70s but like I
was like that weight as 19 20 year old
and then I just obviously go to the gym
and put some muscle on but I've I'm kind
of I'm actually lighter than when I
started at Hawks Bay you know I'm like
most of the time I'm around 121
122 um but people with long laevers long
arms and legs are not built for the gym
let's just say
that no um massive scores like I've been
seeing going around at the moment with
all that camps
and the only one I'll do good at is is a
running test the Bronco not not the
speed but a Bronco yeah what was your
best
Bronco
um I think my best Bronco was a
4 441 or something like that oh yeah
yeah true which was at um start of start
of 219 we did it nice mate you're you're
hising okay next one do you remember
what you said to Aly Williams at meca at
3:00 a.m. before you were in all
black well he claims that I said to him
I'm going to take your jersey one
day I do not recall having this
conversation with Al Williams so it was
a big night on the diesel and I said
that that's what he believes but yeah is
that a story that he said before after
he always goes to me remember that night
McDonald's when you told me you're going
to take my jersey and then he went up to
my after I made my debut he went up to
my mom and said your son he told me one
night that he's going to Jersey and my
mom was like did you say that to
Williams I was like
I do not remember this
but he might be he might have been more
confused than me by
chance both of you to be
fair okay two more did you ever meet
with official Gua fan club in
Vietnam
um I met someone someone one time and
Hamilton come up to me and said this a
the a gasa fan club Vietnam and I was
like what and then they he showed me all
these photos and they had like some
banners up and stuff like that so I'm
not sure if he was an official member
but I've seen I've seen some I've seen
some photos of the setup it wasn't your
cousin no it wasn't my cousin it wasn't
Williams okay what's your dream car to
own dream car oh that's good question
yeah you love it you love the cars yeah
I love my cars these
um I don't know if there's one I could
put it down to I probably I've probably
got them to be fair I've got a little
I've got a little bit of everything i'
got a rot tree I got a V8 got a cruiser
so I'm probably cont of what I've got
that's why that's why you've spent so
much time in Japan or that's why you
signed three years I going to stay here
as long as I
can yeah okay last question best piece
of advice you have for a w Le listener
uh best piece of
advice um if you're going to turn up the
TR tring then give it your best I think
um someone told me that once and like in
hindsight if you're prepared to turn up
and and train then give it everything
and um I guess question that mentality
have I done enough and if you think you
haven't done enough then then do some
more mate I love that it's such a good
way to finish and going through your
your journey the fact that you've never
been dropped um you've only been injured
basically once in 10 years um you've
obviously done that at training you've
um you've put in the effort every time
you've been out there and um the rewards
speak for themselves with what you've
done in in your career and continue to
do um over there in Japan but mate
appreciate you coming on the podcast um
you are a true L true legend of New
Zealand Rugby so it's been awesome to
get you on and go through your career
and um hear how you've done it no thanks
for having me I when I saw your uh post
of the the six Chiefs players and I was
the last one not to uh get on I was like
no I can't I can't leave him fall short
I better get on there so this is
probably the I think I've done one
podcast before this but it's uh it's
been good fun so thanks for having me no
I appreciate it you're a true legend
very good